ونذهب الان الى جولتنا الاخباريه مع شبكه
مراس لمسائل عربيه واليوم نبدا مسائل
عربيه من المدينه المنوره ومع مراسل مساء
العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان يسعد هالمسا
اهلا بك في مسائل عربيه اذا ما تحدثنا عن
ان المدينه المنوره كانت تدشين اول حافله
صديقه للبيئه لخدمه زوار المسجد النبوي لو
نعرف اكثر سلطان على الجهود التي تبذل
لخدمه معتمرين وملايين الزوار الحرم
المدني هذه المره
اهلا بكم واهلا بكافه المشاهدين مساء
العربيه قبل الخوض في تفاصيل هذه الحافله
الكهربائيه الذكيه والصديقه للبيئه نتحدث
ان قامت حافلات مكه وحافلات النقل الترددي
بنقل اكثر من 250 الف مصلي من والى الحرم
المكي عبر تخصيص وتجهيز 300 حافله نقل في
في المدينه المنوره تعمل على نقل
المعتمرين عبر سته او مصلين عبر سته مواقف
دشنا مساء البارحه هذه الحافله الكهربائيه
الذكيه التي دشنت مساء البارحه وهي النسخه
الثانيه في السعوديه في فبراير الماضي كان
هنالك النسخه الاولى في مدينه جده اليوم
نشاهد هذه الحافله الكهربائيه التي تعد
حافله صديقه للبيئه تتجول في شوارع
المدينه من والى من المطار والى المسجد
النبوي والعكس كذلك تستغرق وقت 38 دقيقه
نتحدث على 18
رحله في اليوم تعمل هذه على مدار اليوم
تستغرق فقط شحن لمده اربع الساعات كما
تظهر امامكم هذه الحافله هي مجهزه ومهيئه
بكافه ادوات السلامه وكاميرات المراقبه
بها 27 مقعد تم تخصيصها وقيمه التذكره فقط
11 ريال ونصف تنقوم بنقل المصلي من المطار
والى الحرم المكي والعوده به من متوقع
خلال الفتره القادمه ان نشاهد نسخ اخرى
لهذه الحافله التي تتجول في شوارع المدينه
المنوره وتخدم المصلين نتحدث انه عملت
عليها هيئه النقل العامه ودشنتها مساء
البارحه نتحدث على 16 رحله يوميا تعمل على
مدار 18 ساعه نتحدث على شاشات عرض توضح
للراكبين تفاصيل الرحله والوقت المتبقي
للوصول الى المطار او حتى الى الحرم
النبوي الذي تحدث على مقاعد للاعاقه
ومقاعد للاطفال تم تخصيصها هنا في هذه
الحافله لخدمه دوري الاعاقه ايضا اتحدث
انه هذه الحافله تاتي من ضمن مستهدفات
الاستراتيجيه الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل
وخدمات اللوجستيه نتحدث انه هنالك اهتمام
كبير من الجهات الحكوميه السعوديه
للوصول الى اكبر عدد ممكن من مكابات
الكهربائيه وتطويرها في الفترات القادمه
تتحدثنا عنه هذه الحافله تقوم بخفض
النباتات وانبعاثات الكربونيه بنسبه تصل
الى 25% وكذلك نتحدث انه ترفع نسبه الجوده
النقل في السعوديه نسبه 15% بحلول عشرين
ثلاثين مثل هذه المركبات التي تعتبر من
الخماد تم استخدامها من مواد العالميه
وافضل المنتجات وافضل ادوات السلامه وايضا
تكييف عالي الجوده يستطيع المصلي او
القادم او المسافر من الحرم النبوي المسجد
النبوي الى المطار بهذه الرحله الامنه
والتي بها الشاشات وادوات المراقبه وايضا
هي بها مزوده بعمليه الهيدروليك
امامكم يستطيع انزال هذه الانزال الحافله
على الجانب الايمن وفتح هذا المسار الذي
خصص لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه وكبار السن
ايضا نتحدث على مقاعد لذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه يستودعون الجلوس فيها واستخدام
حزام الامان حقيقه عشنا معك لحظه بلحظه
تفاصيل اول حافله صديقه للبيئه تم تدشين
في المدينه المنوره خبره خدمه زوار المسجد
النبوي على كل حال دائما نذكر بين
السعوديه رائده في هذا المجال مجال لكي
تكون الدون البلدان والدول صديقه للبيئه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]